so I'm glad that you saw the video
recent TBD great stuff during both of
the political conventions and that gives
a sense of something that I'm not sure
that you really saw a whole lot of
during the conventions if you're sort of
watching it on CBS News or other things
Frank Rich who's no great friend of
libertarianism or the Tea Party or
Republicans or me or anybody else he
spent his time during the republican
convention enmeshed in non-traditional
non left-of-center media and his comment
was if you you know surprisingly the
Republican convention was fascinating
with very important philosophical and
ideological battles being waged and if
you wanted to find out about it you
couldn't just read the newspaper he'd
have to go to places like reason he was
highlighting a coverage including what
we did there we'll talk a little bit
about those battles at the convention
I've been covering those things since
2000 both the parties major party
conventions I've never seen anything
like what happened at the Republican
convention this last time this is I
think on the final day the coronation
day this is a protest they're holding up
little yellow sign saying grassroots but
this was a spontaneous protest after
after basically two or three days of the
Republican establishment putting its
boot in the neck of the Ron Paul
movement the Tea Party movement the
Liberty movement these sort of
overlapping groups of people who I think
became a lot better friends during the
republican convention this is some of
the quotes that I got just from that
balcony protested we were railroaded
this is the shot heard around the world
we were absolutely not leaving this
party this is my party I've never seen
so much emotion among people there are
people in tears these are group of
people who were so much more passionate
I mean the standard kind of Republican
Republican or Democratic convention
attendee is and excuse me for those of
you who have been in attending a
delicate they're a little
they're kind of freaks of nature just a
lot of like suspenders and pins and over
enthusiasm and funny hats and you're not
going to get a lot of passionate
dialogue about about changing the
process these people trended to be
compared to the rest very young very
very well informed a lot of 30 year olds
20 you know 28 year olds they tend to be
more female tend to be more minority on
sort of the grassroots upstarts and they
kept saying after all these things
happen to in which I'll get into in a
second we're not leaving this as my
party even though they just kicked me in
the face bill Paulson is Minnesota
delegate here said he was on the Rules
Committee that was going through some of
these things one thing to understand
about the power grab is that it bypassed
a deliberative four-year process they're
trying to control the process they don't
want to see another rampal but they also
don't want to see another rick santorum
the establishment freaked out because
untraditional people rose up and they
had to deal with them and they didn't
like them and they didn't like their
arguments and they didn't like the
people the Ron Paul delegations took
over and got their people involved
especially in caucus States and started
getting involved in the machinery of the
parties in these states and they wanted
to go and they wanted to nominate him on
the floor what they did actually instead
is just changed the rules seriously at
the last minute I going in your supposed
to have five states nominate you to have
your nomination read from the floor Ron
Paul actually got six and so they
changed the rules so you have to have
eight and i think the eighth rule didn't
actually apply to the convention he
passed the five rule on the five state
rule and when the six-state read about
the the chair of the of the proceedings
just wouldn't read people who were
saying that they were nominating Ron
Paul that just refused to sit them they
changed rules this four-year
deliberative process so that the
chairman of the party could just
whenever they want to change the rule
overnight as you saw on the video they
refused to seat various disloyal
delegates and and other things and this
is all an attempt to get rid of or to
control the grassroots procedurally all
everyone who had played by the rules
who learned these arcane caucus
delegation strategy have to sit in the
next meeting in the third meeting from
next Wednesday they learned these arcane
parliamentary procedures better than all
of the existing politicians and so
because they learn the rules so well
they had to change all those rules they
wouldn't have as many Ron Paul people
and tea party people but meanwhile if
you were in the arena looking at the
people who were giving prime time
speaking slots and who were drawing the
most rock star like applause there with
few exceptions they were Tea Party
politicians who went up against the
establishment this was an interesting
quote from Ted Cruz who is now kind of a
darling an up-and-comer in the
conservative statute but he was also
running against the Republican
establishment earlier on on he gave the
speech in which he very studiously avoid
using the phrase Tea Party which was
almost not uttered once on the podium
because people were walking on eggshells
since 2010 something extraordinary has
been happening something that has done
found at the chattering class it began
here in Florida in 2010 in Utah Kentucky
Pennsylvania all of those places are
where candidates who were not supported
by the Republican establishment went up
and first face down the GOP
establishment and then won elections so
you got Marco Rubio Mike Lee who's an
outstanding Senator Rand Paul who will
talk about a little bit more later in
Pat Toomey Ted Cruz became one of those
people I don't like Ted Cruz as much as
I like a ramp all out there but he's
worlds better than what has been the
modal kind of big government Republican
for a long time and so they know the
Republican establishment knows this is
where the all the juices these the
people that are connecting with a
passion that has been bubbling up it
kind of in a revulsion against bailout
economics against obamanomics and
Obamacare they know that's where the
future is there still scared of it they
want to control it they still want to
highlight so this is really great tense
moments and I think right now this is
the national political story that is the
most interesting and granted that's a
pretty low bar generally speaking with
the state of our national politics but
it's this conflict that you see play out
this battle for the soul of the
Republican Party between people who are
actually interested in cutting the size
of government and kind of an
establishment that is more scared so how
are these kind of factions different
you'll find is that the kind of if you
want to call them Rho V and Republicans
Republicans they still even in 2013 even
after fiscal cliff debt ceiling all
these talks after the rice the Tea Party
movement after public poll after public
poll showing that the population wants
to cut spending and not raise taxes they
still don't want to name a single thing
that that the government can cut I think
Carl rope had a piece or a quote no Wall
Street Journal earlier this month or in
January saying well here's the strategy
let's just cut the things that Obama has
proposed cutting so then we can blame it
on him they're terrified Republicans are
of naming anything that they can cut
because they think that they will lose
elections and that's why you saw Mitt
Romney go through all these gymnastics
due to say of course we need to balance
the budget just we of course can't touch
really Medicare or military spending and
I'm going to protect her social security
but we're going to balance that budget
and also I'm not going to tell you
anything that I'm going to cut at all he
said that in a interview of the Weekly
Standard that's sort of the row of
Republican the modal these new people
the rand paul's the world the mike
leigh's they campaign on entitlement
cuts on the long-term fiscal crisis they
can't wait to volunteer what they're
going to abolish next this hasn't
happened this is something that we
haven't seen I was talking to Matt kibbe
earlier I'm still in shock two plus
years later from Rand Paul's first day
on the Senate floor when he stood up and
said first to his Democratic colleagues
you're going to have to change we're
gonna have to reform entitlements you
just can't afford it it's going to
bankrupt the country deal with it and
then he turned to his Republican
colleagues and as a Republican said
you're spending too much money on the
military you can't be serious about
cutting government unless you look at
the military I just hadn't heard that
from a Republican I you know in my
lifetime or from in whatever I remember
from that is the modal position of these
new people including a new wave that
just came in office people like Thomas
Massie in Kentucky
Justin Amash who has been in for now his
second term so they actually want to
name things that they're going to cut
they are talking about foreign policy in
a way that we haven't seen and they tend
to vote no these are the people who
didn't really vote for the fiscal cliff
they're not fans of tarp they're not
fans of Medicare Part D and a lot of
things that Paul Ryan who is otherwise a
very interesting and good politician
would tend to vote YES on and this
faction is growing its growing in
influence it's growing in combativeness
since the election there's been a bunch
of different forums on the future of
conservatism and whither the party and
all this kind of stuff I think the
National Review just hosted a big
national review Institute I took part in
one in commentary magazine kind of
neocon mangoes magazine which I
surprised surprisingly I said that the
libertarianism is a pretty good idea but
there's about 50 commentators in this
thing and it was very interesting to
note how many of them were grappling one
way or the other about libertarianism
being at the heart of what we either
need to do or not do to representative
quotes although there are about a third
of the people who participated in this
we're talking about this in one way or
the other jonah goldberg said that the
key is to revive conservatism zlib ER
tarian brand he's been talking about how
they need to conservatives need to use
federalism to start talking about the
drug war in particular and gay marriage
and some other issues David Brooks a
great old friend of mine talked about
how what we really need to do is combat
freedom ISM which is great he's on the
wrong side of freedom ISM which he
thinks is has taken over a Republican
thought now it's the elevation of
freedom as the ultimate political good
it's just terrible so you have people
who are afraid of and hear the hoofbeats
of a more libertarian based kind of
philosophy and those who see that as
kind of a way to get republicanism both
more rooted in cutting spending and
meaning it for the first time in a
generation and also as a way to approach
issues
more social issues or most socially seen
issues like even immigration so it's
it's fascinating to note that some of
the people who are leading on
comprehensive immigration reform which
you know is not necessarily going to be
something that I'm going to support when
it's in its final legislative forum but
who we're seeing we need to approach
this differently or Marco Rubio art Jeff
Flake who's now in the Senate who's a
great Arizona senator so this conflict
is fascinating to watch we covered very
closely at reason and will be as long as
we've heard all morning you know we're
in there's the one big story that we all
are facing right now it's this sort of
fiscal nightmare that faces us so the
wall of debt the entitlements that are
coming down on and so the question is
who is creating a politics first and
then hopefully policy afterwards that
will begin to cut that three hundred
billion dollars a year that we
apparently need to cut from government
just a keep pace they're so watching
these battle lines between these
factions come out is very instructive in
December John Boehner who has nick has
pointed out does not have an impressive
long life about track record on wanting
to cut anything in government
necessarily um he purged a bunch of kind
of liberty movements libertarian-leaning
congressman from various committees
Justin Amash who is probably the closest
heir apparent to Ron Paul out there and
tim Huelskamp and I'm sure I'd watched
his name from the House Budget Committee
David Schweikert from Arizona Walter
Jones from the Financial Services
Committee this was just these guys are a
big pain in our rear ends because they
won't vote for our compromises and they
keep criticizing us for wanting to work
for not wanting to cut spending on there
is a quote you can cover your ears if if
it's too early in the morning for for
working blue but one of the people close
to Boehner said basically it had nothing
to do with their philosophy lafa chol
differences of us it's just that all
these guys are egregious [ __ ] which
isn't true but what I mean they are only
in the sense that they are actually
sticking up for principles that
Republicans
long talked about but having acted on
for a long time and so in January Amash
and these guys return the favor there
was a coup you might have read about or
attempted semi pathetic little challenge
to banners speakership that came from
Justin Amash he was a ringleader of this
a lot of these liberty-minded
Republicans either voted for each other
or voted for or voted for people who
weren't even in the house but they
didn't vote for Boehner they tried to go
behind his back has been portrayed
mostly by the national media as kind of
a failed and pathetic attempt by people
who were disorganized I think that you
can make an analogy to maybe some of the
nominations for people like christine
o'donnell Sharron Angle saying yes we'll
lose but you just heard that bullet
whizzed past you're here we want to
change your behavior going forward which
has been a hallmark of tea party
strategy in particular other bad lines
going on there's all these ongoing
battles of state Republican parties
everywhere you had a rampal guy from
Maine Maine as a large source of these
conflicts mark Willis he tried to go
against rents Priebus inu he's going to
lose but they want to know that you're
being challenged by this faction right
now Paul people run Iowa and Nevada and
bunch and are very prominent in various
other state delegations I think just
yesterday or the day before a Paul
loyalists got bounced from Alaska in a
pretty cagey way so watch these
conflicts going forward a major one is
sort of symbolized between the
Crossroads GPS is of the world of call
Rove's on club for growth of the world
people who are using the primary process
to make these fights and change the
attitudes of the Republican Party there
is a big wave after the election among
more establishment GOP of like we have
to stop this primary insanity to use
that our money pot to make that not
happen to go after groups that are doing
this so this will be a battleground
going forward because I don't think that
the club for growth FreedomWorks Tea
Party groups I don't think that they're
stopped primary and we can hear some
some comments from Matt hopefully
afterwards talking about some of this
going forward on so another way this is
manifesting is in the 2016 presidential
race don't know who's running yet but
you can go out we do know that Rand Paul
is running for sure but certainly Paul
Ryan is in the mix and he's someone who
even if you hate his voting record he
did bring entitlement reform into the
national discussion and deserves a lot
of credit doing that he'll be writing
the house budget or you know being a key
into that as they try to advance that
conversation so he's someone who
believes in fiscal conservatism regrowth
of how he acts Marco Rubio who is you
know much more interesting to Mitch
McConnell certainly Bobby Jindal has
also seen to someone and I don't know if
you caught his sort of ballyhooed speech
that he gave the other day which was
sort of all over the map he was talking
about positioning mostly but in the
middle of all of this he gave one of the
most kind of radically libertarian
things I've heard in a long time from a
major politician or purportedly major
politician if any rational human being
were to create our government anew today
from a blank piece of paper we would
have about one-fourth of the buildings
we have in Washington and about half of
the government workers he also said we
wouldn't have social insurance programs
and other stuff so in the sense that
presidential contests are national
conversations about politics and
ideology and policy it is interesting to
note that I don't know half of the
handful of people who are out there that
being heavily considered as possible
epic comers on the Republican side are
people who overlap a lot more with the
libertarian esque worldview which is
interesting and reason for encouragement
I think at this point some of you who
have heard me or Nick talked once or
twice before might be saying wait aren't
you the guys are always saying that
political parties you're stupid and we
shouldn't talk about them or get excited
about them to which I say you didn't
read the whole book because we also
talked about the ways that you can use
the technologies and the strategies of
Independence to try to get these old
husks of political groupings to start
being more responsive to your needs and
that is exactly what we do
happen in great numbers in a way that I
think none of us could have really
predicted you know in the middle of 2008
I think I wrote one of my first editor's
note columns in 2008 was about you know
when coalition's political coalition's
dissolve and I kind of posited that the
long kind of coalition membership
between some traditional conservatives
and libertarians it lost its mojo it
might be breaking apart it might be
reformulating it'd be really hard to
have predicted at that moment that we'd
see kind of a generational surge in in
thinking about some of these ideas so
this is this is I think very optimistic
we're finally beginning to see maybe the
first example of this happening on the
Democratic side in El Paso a guy who
used to be a city councilman named bado
Roark he pry married an incumbent or
favored Democrat against the
establishment on the issue the drug war
they're going to be I predicts ish that
over the next four years or so we're
going to see kind of a disaffection from
the liberal coalition as obamanomics is
again revealed to be a failure and just
the usual second term itís that uh
flicks him it flicks everybody there's
going to be people peeling off and
they've been studying as much as they
hate the Tea Party they've been studying
it the Occupy Wall Street they studied
the Tea Party they're thinking about
ways of copying those things and what
happens anytime both parties or the kind
of governing establishment acts for a
long period of time to the contrary of
the wishes either of majority of the
population or a majority within one of
the political factions that is
inherently unstable because of
Technology and because of the way that
people are learning how to use
independence as a weapon usually not
always usually some of these issues go
into a more libertarian direction I
think a very interesting place to look
for that happening in the future has to
do with foreign policy and military
spending um so watch this space and
particularly watch this man Rand Paul
who i think has been really really
interesting as the cover line says on in
this process he
has managed he's a guy who will talk
about to certain audiences things like
blowback he endorses much of his
father's world view but he talks about
it differently in such a way they can go
on Sean Hannity and talk about these
things he can go on on Rush Limbaugh he
so in 2010 right I think right before
right after the Tea Party wave election
happened and I'm going to close here and
hopefully we'll get comments from people
who are actually in the process like
John Utley and Jeff singer and Matt
kibbe and and other people but in 2010
so like welcome to Washington tea party
you're great on this cutting spending
but don't you dare touch military
spending this is the odd I think a
pretty notorious op-ed in the Wall
Street Journal from EDD fullner
president of heritage foundation than at
the time Arthur Brooks self-described
libertarian head of American Enterprise
Institute and William Kristol a great
friend of libertarianism for a long time
they just said you know welcome but
you're not going to touch military
military spending is not a spending
problem I think there's a near direct
quote from that it is interesting to
note as we look at this rise of a still
minority faction than that even as the
tea party people were given a bit of the
back of the hand in 2010 by the
president of heritage Rand Paul next
week on wednesday is going to give a
major speech on foreign policy at the
heritage Institute he is not just
talking to Kate oh he's not just talking
to us he is trying to take these values
and talk about them to a crowd that has
not been very receptive to it for a
while and he's doing it and he's
maintaining the respect of people who
otherwise have been on the outside or
who might hate his father for example
which i think is very an interesting and
positive development we will see where
that goes i still think that on on
particularly on questions of foreign
policy military spending the dominant
republican strain is not on rand paul
side but he's attempting to begin an
arguments and articulations which is
sort of the precondition for changing
minds so I'm optimistic in a limited way
because he
never look for to Washington or
politicians for your your salvation in
the world certainly but the quality of
conversation is changing in a way that
is I think grounds for at least slight
optimism on the Republican Party thanks
to people like that and with that I'll
stop and take questions and hopefully
hear from people who are more in at nine
you